now how many parents out there would
love I want you to raise your hands if
you would love for your children to have
cancer go ahead and raise your hands
how about diabetes raise your hand say
aye how about for your children to be
obese overweight
how about heart disease any parents out
there raising their hands right now I
don't think any sane parent who truly
loves their child would like for their
child to have cancer diabetes heart
disease that the question and it's of
itself you think is just not sensible
it's crazy but what if I told you that
many parents unintentionally with I'm
sure with lot of love for their children
are unconsciously helping to contribute
to their children having cancer diabetes
heart disease what would you think what
would you say then because this is the
truth and I'm gonna share some simple
there's brilliance in simplicity I'm
gonna share some very simple yet
profound advice with you from someone is
not literally a Mufti or Cher but
someone that you so you can equate that
because usually when someone is of this
stature you say wow they have a lot of
knowledge so this person in this area is
an expert in the science of food in
nutrition and this is somewhat one of my
teachers and I want to share this simple
yet profound advice easy to understand
easy to digest and this can be a
catalyst from here for you to take off
with pay attention so an important point
of awareness remember that we come into
this world needing only one food the
milk from our mother's breasts I mean
this is this is what the Almighty Allah
talks about in the Quran for two years
that the mother should be bright
feeding this is like the most powerful
foundation that you can build your child
upon to have such a strong immune system
to set them off for the rest of his life
of course at two three years of age
there are other nutritious foods that
children can enjoy and benefit from and
allowing your child to try a variety of
foods has value but variety should not
overly be emphasized also and
unfortunately it is common in our junk
food and fast food convenience food
dominated culture for adults to project
their own tastes but exciting food
preferences and addictions unto your
unto your children so he talks about
nutritionist expert Jim Marlowe talks
about how parents they end up projecting
their food preferences on their children
so we see this happening a lot that
parents they have an addiction to a
certain food they like a certain food
it's a junk food fast food whatever it
is they end up projecting what they like
on to their kids and they corrupt their
kids sweets and other refine and process
carbohydrates that have addictive
qualities can corrupt a child's
tastebuds and cause a child to lose
touch with the nutritional instinct that
they were born with feeding your child
high-quality nutrient-dense wholesome
food which I suggest that you think of
simply as real food helps to strengthen
a child's nutritional instinct more than
a few times over the years I have heard
from mothers with children who had
uncorrupted tastebuds about how their
child loves liver and has no interest in
eating sweets now you think liver that's
nasty but
I used to hate liver let's take this
example here a living example but when I
learned how beneficial liver is for
example that's one out of the many real
foods that are out there I read in my
taste buds
I found that liver was something that
our parents would eat and their parents
would eat they were onto something but
today the child's tastebuds have been so
corrupted with eating fake foods
chemicalized processed junk foods they
don't like the real food but when we
when we train ourselves to eat to live
not living to eat it's a totally
different experience so ivory educated
myself to love something that's
beneficial for me liver being the most
nutrient deck dense food you get the
most bang for your buck unfortunately
but not surprisingly it is rare for a
child in our culture not to have some
degree of carbohydrate addiction by the
age of 2 or 3 the adult world around
them encourages it ice cream cookies
candy and other sweets are used by
nutritionally unconscious adults to
reward children now many of us with the
best with the best love for our children
we end up corrupting their taste buds we
end up corrupting their bodies by
rewarding them with fake junk toxic
foods and a simple way to substitute
that is to reward them with real foods
the real food that the Almighty has
given us with a banana date with an
apple with an orange not with something
toxic with something poor with something
that's actually damaging when we talked
about earlier the skyrocketing number of
statistics of heart disease cancer
obesity diabetes and kids their teeth
just falling you think Allah made the
teeth that you know they're supposed to
fall out that soon I mean we've seen
says that their teeth have in dead
bodies have gone on to continue to be
preserved it's the food that is
destroying not only the children's teeth
but everything else in their body he
says I share all of this with you in
support of emphasizing the following
hard-earned wisdom you know that many
people have to struggle
they have to seek knowledge they had to
you know go through a lot to get this
information and you're getting it to you
is very simple so this hard-earned
wisdom he says be consciously careful
about what foods you allow your children
to be introduced to the commercial food
industry is expert at imparting
addictive qualities into the highly
processed chemicalized products that
they sell as food in addition to making
the most of the addictive qualities of
sugar and refined starches now we're
finishing up here powerful simple
profound advice he says I strongly
support that children should be
protected from these fake food products
as much as practically possible rather
than being encouraged to partake in them
what's fake food fake food is anything
with a list of ingredients that you
can't pronounce your grandparents didn't
recognize as real food it's something
that's gone through the human process
for longer shelf life on the shelves
something toxic you put in your body has
addictive elements has no nutritional
value Krispy Kreme Dunkin Donuts
pop-tarts snicker bar an Oreo cookie ice
cream someone might say what's the big
deal I reward them once in a while no
the big deal is did you raise your hand
in the beginning I said would you like
for your child have cancer heart disease
obesity nobody raised their hands
but the big deal is that when you come
to know that sugar-white processes are
fine high fructose corn syrup
white sugar brown sugar these kind of
sugars are highly they're there they're
pumped into the majority of these fake
food items they're addicted eight seven
to eight times more addictive than
cocaine so now when your child's
climbing up in the cupboards he's
looking for this food he's addicted he's
having mood swings crying he won't eat
deliver he won't eat the real food the
veggies the banana the Apple the real
food that the almighty that Allah gave
us but he's smart but he can't
distinguish what's nutrition he
nutritionally beneficial and what's
actually destroying and helping to
produce cancer in his body
diabetes and all these other health
disorders because of the fake food
chemicalized food that now you're
putting in your child's body you don't
want him to have cancer or any of these
things you didn't raise your hands did
you know you did because you love your
child so if you love your child then do
what's best for your child for yourself
eat real food
take this profound simple yet profound
advice and I'm telling you that if you
implement this and you live by it you
will see tremendous changes in your
health and your child's health you will
help to protect your child from these
chronic health disorders you won't be
contributing to the demise of your your
health or your child's health so
community leaders in the must use we
shouldn't have coca-cola parties ice
cream cake cookies you can you can
substitute the ingredients in a cookie
with natural ingredients find out what
they are we don't have time for this in
this video you can substitute the
snicker bars the toxic remember these
things again help to feed the cancers
help to destroy your child's help so why
not replace it with a real food a date
you know the date it's a real food a
living food
an apple a banana and orange instead of
the ice cream and the cookies and all of
this other garbage because you care for
your kid and you don't want them to have
cancer follow this profound yet simple
advice of keeping the fake food
chemicalized food away from your home
from your family train your kids to
develop nutritional to integrity
yourself first and foremost and then
projecting good values of nutrition on
to your kids and you will help to
protect them again you didn't raise your
hand because you don't want that for
your child but if you continue to go on
you're not raising your hand but you
actually are because you're helping to
contribute to your child if you don't
follow this advice to tomorrow having
cancer an epidemic amongst kids today
something that was unheard of at a
certain time some time back but today
this the number of kids that are dying
from these thing not expected to the
first generation of kids not expected to
outlive their parents because of the
toxic fake foods that they're eating in
the parents the kids aren't going to to
this to the store buying stuff you're
buying it so you got to stop and I'm
gonna leave you with some homework a
great documentary to watch is fed up or
sugar-coated and if you can do this
simple state is to eliminate the sugar
the high fructose corn syrup the this is
a great catalyst a great place to start
and keep it simple it's not convoluted
something abstruse and hard to
understand real food is our god-given
right a law had had given it to us you
know 50 hundred years ago there's no
such thing as organic food it was just
real food cooking the stuff at home
rewarding them with real foods a give
you example of a banana and an apple a
date right now you're like they won't
eat that of course you've been cut using
you already corrupted them so now you
got to reintroduce it eliminate the fake
food incorporate the real food into your
life and your family's life and then you
will live the difference you will see
the difference in your health and your
children's health and what do I have to
benefit
only to the reward from the Almighty and
out of love I'm I really see so many
kids affected so many parents so many
people's help being affected and there's
such a simple simple yet profound
solution out there if you just implement
you start off with implementing this
simple yet profound advice from an
expert in this area and you'll see in
Charlotte God willing the benefits thank
you Salaam alaikum peace be with you